ah on va faire l'interview disant gamine
disons gamine t'aurais pas voulu être la
fille de gad en moi non il ya un acteur
aujourd'hui qu'il fait penser à moi
aucun il paraît que tous les jeunes
connaissent les tontons flingueurs
parker ça te rend fier non pas
particulièrement
tu touches des sous sur le dvd qui sort
tout pas non mais sur le lino sur le
linoléum jelly à alain d'accord aulas
et disons gamine tu m'en veux d'avoir
appelé clélia ah non je suis désolé
j'étais bourré non il a mis huit jours
n'étaient pas assez dans le calendrier
ça existait pas oui alors il a dit moi
je reviendrai plus tard et ça s'est
passé pendant cinq jours g/j pas eu de
nom ils ont dominé ce que tu sais faire
les pattes maintenant on est comme ça
j'en suis fier tu as peur de me
ressemblent en vieillissant non du tout
au contraire et des choses que tu aurais
même dire plein sur les hommes sur la
vie sur plein de questionnements surtout
pourquoi tu me parlais pas parce que tu
étais pas facile lille en gamine s'est
tu fais pas chier de devoir me parlait à
travers ardisson j'aurais adoré ma femme
parle d'un islandais
c'est bien aventure à lino tout
simplement j'ai robert laffont bellamy
et